close your eyes good good keep them
closed don't look at anything that's
happening on the screen right now you
don't want to know why is this why is my
taskbar always
on top now
stop
stop it I think I need to reboot my
computer I'll be right back
yes I'm Gonna Save this this is part one
of two of the video this is Alexian edit
or Marcus and Rachel
Thank You
Close Your Eyes again
getting close I know you're looking I
know either you're looking right now you
need to close your eyes those of you who
are closing your eyes you're doing very
good those of you who aren't
you're being very bad anyway keep them
close through the whole video let's see
who can go the longest comment when you
open your eyes with the exact time code
of when you opened your eyes and then
we'll have a competition to see who
lasted the longest
but you gotta make it to the end if you
want to win all right new game this is a
game about opening and closing your eyes
or at least not looking at the things
that you don't want to look at or your
demons that are standing in the corner
of your room right now in the shadows
just waiting for you to turn around and
open your eyes but don't do it don't
open your eyes salutations client A4 d32
you probably feel they're still feeling
very hard right now this is completely
normal it'll only be a few months before
you feel back to normal until then let's
run through standard procedure to get
ready for your planned release on July
4th
2057. that's a ways away uh I'm blind
hello name Cecily Newman sex not
applicable
hmm age four hours weight
1437 pounds height five six uh
insufficient data blood type not
applicable
um
I don't know what this means do you feel
any pain swelling itch blink for me
three times
uh how are your legs feeling I needed I
thought it was sitting am I not I
thought I was sitting in a chair
that cup
that covers it now wait here until a
view employee comes to give you further
instructions okay
hmm
I guess I'm not going to follow the
instructions okay
why
oh it's like Slenderman when the big
thumpy thumps we're thumping up storm in
the woods
lyxian flashes back to the the wonderful
year of 2012.
when we were playing Slender the Eight
Pages hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome back to the very
original Slender game good time
actually I think I gotta go get that
hold on we're going on a bit of an
adventure close your eyes I'm going to
show you something close your eyes close
your eyes guys close your eyes close
your eyes
close your eyes Okay found it I haven't
been on nddb in ages I used to be on
ndtb all the time now it's ichio and
game Jong to a lesser extent and steam
for an even more robust experience but
it's Slender version
.97 it never actually got a full release
I never actually beat it did you know
that I've never actually beaten Slender
the original one I beat all the other
ones but I've never actually beaten the
Slenderman let's take a little detour
why not come on and adventure with me
why wouldn't we do this that's perfectly
normal what are you talking about
ah the memories look at this look at
that guy oh yeah that was no good way to
zoom in I'll just open them up for you
you remember this [ __ ]
God man does it make you piss your pants
back in the day and now nothing's
working anymore just bad that did just
shot itself so it's it's not showing
anything why'd my internet [ __ ] itself
that
and then
[ __ ] Christ
just show me the pictures everybody hold
on just hold on this is apparently not
going very well
what the [ __ ] yeah out of memory how
much memory did how many pictures of
Slenderman was there
but my god I've got a lot of games in
this folder that I need to play you
wanna you guys want to see what the the
pending to be recorded game folder this
isn't including me downloading games off
a video or anything or steam or
something is it ha there you go that's
uh that's what you get to see
a little preview of things to come uh
yeah I don't know why that's but anyway
Alexian put up a whole bunch more
pictures of the Slenderman I'm gonna see
if this game from like 10 years ago can
play while this other game is playing in
the background and see if I can still
record it all I bet I can
computer's good these days right oh
the freaking oh
God it's been a while the Slenderman
Mythos wow
[Music]
I remember
oh and I'm not talking about all those
knockoff Slender games which I played
all of like Slender Elementary and stuff
like that
no no that was that was I believe that
was just a cash grab it's like a new
game every two weeks great for Content
but I could you know you knew you knew
what it was all about anyway let's get
into it
oh oh The Click
oh how do I jog
so there's walking and then there's
jogging
not sure what the difference is
how do you jog wait let me there's a
read me right jog Sprint it's the same
thing what do you mean jogging sprinting
causes jogging sprinting causes your
stamina to drop it recovers when walking
what do you mean sprinting what
what
what are you talking about
what is there another way to
print
I'm so confused I don't know what
sprinting's about I'm trying to get cozy
in my chair hold on hold on slendy man
hold on slendy man I just I wish God you
know gaming chairs are such [ __ ]
right I don't want wheels on my chair I
want to stay in one place because I
fidget a lot because I'm always moving
if my wheels are moving then I can't
stay in one fidgety spot all comfortable
like
anybody else get what I'm saying
whatever I don't remember
where anything is I don't remember how
to jog
rent
Slenderman
[Music]
Slenderman
I have no bearing on where I am so I
don't remember wearing the actual pages
is
oh there we go it's like the rock things
whatever those are supposed to be I I
isn't it a thing where they're not
guaranteed to be able to hold up never
mind can't run
you're right about that I don't even
know how
oh there it is that's the sound that's
why I did this oh yeah
oh yeah now that's what I'm talking
about
I still don't understand the difference
between sprinting and jogging it seems
to be I don't have any distinction
between the two
I'm not going to look at the
instructions now
man I did not have the wherewithal or
discipline to try to beat it back in the
day
more more importantly I was like a
little [ __ ] baby so I definitely didn't
have the wherewithal my screamatude was
just a little bit immature if you know
what I mean
I didn't have the discipline of 10 years
of Hard YouTube labor
to strengthen me up to be able to beat
Mr man I don't know where this thing is
it also just might not be here so it
could be somewhere else anywhere else I
can't get comfortable
ah oh hello
oh that's handy
oh my goodness I've almost forgotten
I've got oh such familiar chills still
my spine right my goodness the Slender
Man back at it again ah this is so fun
but the thing is if I come in here won't
I just get trapped
this is not the thing that'll happen ooh
is that a page that is Paige no no no
yes yes yes
yes please
yeah I'm not seeing any different words
I'm not seeing any difference in the
stamina
and the stone
I forget how he moves this is weird I'm
like reverting back to my older selfie I
don't
know oh it's fine it's just me out of
breath
oh he's there somewhere you're there
somewhere slendy man don't try to get me
whoa
okay so I am breathing so it's something
about I gotta stop I I'm uncomfortable
Slenderman
that's what I thought
that's what I thought he's right there
where were you I don't know
whatever buddy
I don't even remember if it's a good
idea to keep looking at him or to look
away and
I don't know he seems to be gone he does
kind of disappear sometimes but I don't
I never I don't think I ever really
learned the logic
I don't really know any of the lore and
I know that the movie came out and it's
like yeah it was not a good movie or
something like that
it's amazing how they just get people to
[ __ ] those things up over and over again
not me though never me wow no that's the
opposite of good I forgot the packing
games when they were just like oh no
come on
okay we're good we're good give me give
me yes oh yeah
I forgot that the mouse could just go
out of the game and then totally blown
me over when I'm trying to do something
God wait no the expression of me saying
bone me over isn't that like didn't I
only ever say that back in the day I
don't think I've said that in a long
time I think I am reverting back to my
old self because someone put up a side
by side comparison of me and me playing
the me now and me playing this back then
I'm gonna I want to see I want people to
witness it I want people to witness the
change that when people say that
Markiplier has changed now they've got
direct evidence of it irrefutable
irrefutable what is my stamina ever
going to recover
twice as fast when you're standing still
apparently
well where where where where where I
don't oh there he is okay I gotta go
over here because that's where the next
Landmark is you Dingus dingus
keep going holy crap a new one oh hey
hey
you don't actually get to scare me what
the hell is that about no that's not
okay that's not that ain't cool that
ain't cool at all I know that there's
prob oh yeah oh yeah I got four I got
four what of it now what of it now
yeah I don't know where he is
what if it now I got four I'm probably
getting them in a completely illogical
order that's gonna screw me over when I
try to make this loop around this place
that's a good thing you're only going
faster
certainly scared me as much as it did
oh boy okay well this is a problem uh
let's cancel
um
a lot is Gonna Stand still for a bit oh
goodness
oh it's real staticky
I can't see [ __ ]
oh
did I go back oh dude I went backwards
didn't I oh I gotta go can I how do I I
don't know how to sprint versus jog I
don't know anything I don't know nothing
I know I know nothing who's there God
why is it scary this shouldn't be scary
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's just standing there
Madison
wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute I went in a circle and I
didn't mean to I gotta cut through the
woods always a good idea cut through the
darkest part of the woods God I miss
Darkwood God I wish it was more dark
wood God I'm pissed off about that
ending in dark wood where it screwed me
over totally screwed me over and it
wasn't my fault I liked one one shot all
of that right up at dillian and then it
screwed me over right then and there I
don't like it totally unfair but God I
love Darkwood okay he's back
all right where are you going baby oh
there you are well there you are oh God
I don't know why it decides to do that
why do that go away
oh frick well I'm not doing this right
well no
oh man he's uh he's persistent if I get
him like behind a truck I can't see
anything if I get him like behind a tree
is that okay I think it is unless he's
gone he's gone he moved again well don't
know the rules about that maybe I just
gotta wait him out maybe that's what I
was doing before I was just starting to
panic and I was just like letting myself
die when in reality everything was going
to be fine
halfway there to Victory apparently
I'm uncomfortable
yeah God I needed they need to invent a
different chair one that you don't sit
on your butt I like to just like squat
in chairs I like to cross my legs and
I don't know sit on my feet whatever
I just need a different chair I've never
looked into it I've only been like I've
I've only ever used like a kitchen chair
or I've been gifted chairs like chairs
just seem to appear somehow I don't know
how but they do where am I
uh anybody have any recommendations
write in the comments below ring that
Bell if you know a recommendation for
the chair
you know they didn't have a bell when
this game first came out you know
usually he's just when you subscribe he
just subscribe to people I guess you
know
whatever if you want to like soft
subscribe hello
where is he
I don't see him I ain't sorry I'm not
seeing him
I was not seeing him I don't know what
that was about
well he's gone now oh goody five surely
death is not right behind me
oh
yeah
[Music]
rumbling in my door
rumbly in my tumbly you say
okay I oh oh that's a fence I um I might
be lost
I might be lost alone in the woods if I
if I pop out at that truck again I'm
gonna be real mad I'm going to be so mad
I'm gonna be real mad
okay so far no slendy man
where where where where where where
[Music]
don't do that whoa what's going on is he
right by always climbing up my ass he's
climbing up my ass he's climbing up my
ass he's climbing up
nobody do it
don't do it what are you doing what
happened where was he huh where is he is
he here where is he why what what
happened
I don't know what happened
I think he must have been like on the
other side of the brick wall and he was
stuck there foreign
I'm really trying to get comfortable but
it's not working because it's either
this this chair is too short
or whatever have you we're too dull I
gotta like readjust it on the Fly and
then readjust my legs and then get
cramps because I can't stick my legs
back through it it's just so ugh
it's just so designed for ass sitters
and now I'm too
I'm gonna stay like this for a bit I'm
gonna see if I can anyway all right well
that was fun but that's not why we're
here this is a different game this
and now you see why I did this if I
could close my eyes there that'd be
really great
uh hello
it's gonna be Markiplier here back at it
again thinking that click is open doors
but it's not
yep yep yeah yeah
okie dokie then blink Blanc
foreign
[Music]
all right now I I you know I would not
be good in an emergency because I
wouldn't know to evacuate I would just
stand around well hi there
oh good
oh good good hold still I'm holding
still I guess am I supposed to
oh
I'm not gonna do it
I ain't holding still for nobody
I don't sit still and I ain't holding
still for you hi
is was that the dying of a cringe sound
I feel like that was
whoa
interesting well I can see in the
Darkness
wow oh wow
interesting
huh fascinating
oh fascinating
oh
interesting all right so this is fun
this is good mechanics I kind of like
this
oh
why I see you I see you and I see you
fascinating it's kind of clever I kinda
like it I kinda like it a lot
um
it goes
you'll have to deal with it
hello so what's going on in here wow a
key card
oh God
I can't see oh why okay
oh boy oh boy
oh so how unstable is the facility uh
you say
how uh how bad is it how about
I can't look at that why couldn't I look
at that
oh
Israel rumbly
I shouldn't have touched it
nah okay okay what
I want to go again I want to go again
okay so I think what I have to do is I
have to drop that ball and then make it
scream as it greens down and break
something down at the bottom I don't
know how I'm gonna do that well yes I do
yeah I do I do
I use the saw from The Tool Shed I don't
know what you mean by Tool Shed
um also I don't know what that's about
unless that's an eyeball that you put in
my head and then I have a similar device
which might be true but I don't know
oh hello
oh
oh
wow
[Music]
hmm there's a lot of big rumblies around
here oh 264.
huh
oh I see it's a puzzle because it's like
no no so it must be two three four you
can't fool me I'm way too smart
hello
it's two three four I'm so God damn
smart
[Music]
right in my brain
[Applause]
hope I left that door open
I'd like to think that I did high
voltage I don't know why I tried to
touch it immediately I really did okay
so I need two power things to open the
tool shed apparently that's how tool
sheds work in my book
oh
I can't read that okay what does that
saying attention all of you Personnel
Huss can kill if you were attacked by a
husk cover your eyes and carefully walk
to the nearest exit
okay
um so is there a Husk in here like right
now or something
oh I don't like
like the truth be told I do not like
that
I hate this
I hate this
I hate this oh hello you d
oh
[Music]
I hate that yeah
my God what are you doing being scary
stop it
oh what was that
peekaboo no all right okay all right
peekaboo what's up with your face
okay no none of that no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
you're Slappy so I'm uh supposed to
all right I'm supposed to know that Huss
can kill right so husk you're supposed
to be able to kill me huh I believe it
you know what I I do believe it oh what
happened
ho ho
nice
you still back there sloppy he's still
back there slappy
for anyone who was curious I am now
sitting side saddle in my chair
because I thought you should know anyway
that was two power supplies I need to go
up open the tool shed grab the saw
because all this was just for that saw
and nothing else
and then I need to cut the eyeball and
drop it on the thing
good thing no this sauce so
here
I don't know why that needed so much so
much power to open up that little that
one shutter
I feel like I could have just pushed
that open lifted it with my big strong
muscles I could have done literally
anything did you get that
and I didn't oh well
I'm gonna guess that there's some kind
of like life with this orb and doing
this is actually a bad thing but I'll do
it anyway
I just slapped that thing's ass
I slapped it down with my big meaty
claws right in its ass and it went
careening into the void
I feel so good about myself
anyway
so what did that do oh God it is awfully
Smoky down there
strange
strange
I can't see [ __ ]
hey you feel uh I didn't know there was
a hole in the ground
I legitimately did not know that
okay
okay
hello hi this definitely doesn't look
like a place for something to kill me oh
great
well is this really any different
I'll just
make my way then
hate it oh hello I don't hate it
oh do I get that or not
I'm guessing not
I'm guessing not hello
awfully strange how much sewer access
these buildings usually have hi
okay
uh-huh
uh-huh
uh-huh
is there uh
so we're gonna be something down here
what's uh what's all that then
uh-huh
what look look at what
what was that all about I
look
look uh
oh
okay that's good
good hello
is somebody there peekaboo I can fit in
here somehow I didn't think I could
holy crap
hello
is there someone under there that wants
to say hello
oh no
he's gone
oh and fast too all right
sure sure sure sure sure sure
what
okay hello
I can't see anything
seems to be closed off here
uh uh inaccessible
I can't get over there
whatever this is it's blocked oh wait no
it's not
oh I see
aha
oh
I thought I was gonna regret it view
success as mandatory okay oh
was that bucket for blood
do I gotta put blood in the bucket or
something well I need to add power to
that so then I can turn on the elevator
power and then I can get out of here or
something like that hello peekaboo
oh wait this is just the other side of
that I do have a key card here
I'm not 100 sure where it goes whoa key
card door here
oh oh
you
yeah this guy here oh you jokester
anyway man everything is the same squeak
oh man really funny really good stuff
guys really good stuff hi Larry is
hijinks
oh good stuff anyway I'm gonna turn on
the elevator and I'm getting the heck
out of here
I'm gonna live I'm surviving to fight
another day
all right guys I'll see you around I'll
see ya see you around actually see you
around I'll see you guys around I'll see
you around see you around guys see you
around I'll see you around guys I'll see
you around I ain't turning around for
nothing
okay in Wii uh
oh you coming after me
you oh you're gonna come after me oh you
want to come after me oh no I don't
think so
oh you're gonna come back no I don't
know
think so yeah I don't think so I'm going
back to the elevator and then I'm gonna
well that ain't good
oh oh man I did it
idiot stupid fool I'm uncomfortable
again
hello it's me
okay
oh
oh hello
ah
wow oh is that what happened to me
did I get a bunch of green goop injected
into my eyes
wow oh look at that you got a green eye
[Music]
dude
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] hey bud how you doing
good to see you does this release you
God I hope so
uh it seemed to weirdly enough okay
[Laughter]
oh God still hate it okay all right well
I did that so should I I don't I don't
know what to do about that
[Music]
hmm
there's something going on from here to
there
definitely something happening
I can't go through there
I can't do anything with that
that's there
this can't be touched I don't see oh
level down uh
super dark in here
so it must be something in here
oh now I can do this oh once I opened up
that one I could do this here ah you
wink nevermind
oh God where am I whoa no thank you
we went low res oh oh oh oh
uh-huh
yeah
uh-huh
uh-huh oh oh oh ah
uh-huh oh
oh
uh-huh
yeah
uh-huh
um
I can't think of anything really clever
to say about any of this I don't know if
you guys can uh the comments would be a
good place to inform me of really clever
things to say about what I'm seeing in
front of me right now I would really
love that oh good
let's all take those thanks
oh no
oh
thank you I can't move
ah three two three
helpful thank you for that I don't want
to go back in that memory
323 it is I'm not gonna go in that room
all right I'll look
you still there all right he's still
there all right three two three
all right we're in baby
oh oh oh oh
why what happened I missed it oh what is
this all about what the hell is this all
about what is this all about where is
there I was just saying there was just a
sewer here unless I wasn't a sewer and
it was just a canal in this area but
what is all this about
wait a minute
wait hey what are you doing up there I
see you
Lucy and zoom zoom more zoom zoom zoom
zoom enhance
perfect thank you
jump scare
um okay oh
I love learning what is cognitive
transference Vitality saved in the
entity's yielded Essence storage
our eyes for short identity stored in
the eyes is installed on the host
entities husks are sent to sector a23
a25 for testing and mutilation
you can just burn it I guess don't need
to mutilate it what's that all about why
are there buttons on there I see you
all right so this seems like a real
crackpot company huh
it's you steal their eyes and you steal
their soul and that's all you need to
know that's all you love power
strength Vitality identification
extracted for
oh
hi
that's a bad acronym I'm not gonna lie
not really the best acronym place you
know what I mean
ah good hi um hello wow very
endoskeleton of you
um you're looking at me which is awesome
and I love that
um but if you could blow up that'd be
great beep
all right bluegate it is all right see
you sir ma'am
that's none of my concern
no
oh good hey what's up here oh what is up
my Bros
Barrel am I right
okay
um
I don't know where that's supposed to be
yet oh well that's not good
okay three barrels okay there's four
barrels there's three chairs and two
tables
okay chair Barrel there's four
three chairs
there's four barrels
and two two tables ah red Gabe open red
red gate open good
good
uh don't know why doing any of this
this is all very good
okay
oh no no
no
no
oh no
oh no
[Music]
oh he was so young or older whatever I
don't know how age is determined
post I rip transferences
are you still back there well if you
were a husk you'd be coming after me I'm
assuming that you're just totally fine
then excuse me I need to go in this room
now
up I go
ah good great oh behind X or behind me
right now
okay so behind X
B hind X
all right
behind I see an X over there am I
supposed to go behind it okay there is a
big X I'm I'm just assuming that that's
what you mean
oh oh looky looky looky there
oh oh thank you I'm very clever you know
there's a lot of cleverness going on
everyone hold on to your butts things
are about to get real serious
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh Crouch yes of course
I didn't do any of that I didn't do that
oh
my God
oh God am I spine my eyes
ah wake up sleep wait I don't know which
one's the right answer wake up wake up
wake up sleep
wake up I wake up
all right so what did I just see down
there
as you guys saw that too right
oops
oh hey bud
not looking at you
not looking at you
okay we're good
crouching under here okay
crash okay we're good
very far very far away
oh yeah oh yeah we got this oh yeah
we're locked in tight
oh I need a key card for there we gotta
watch out for these valsies oh man
you're oh
stop you don't need to
oh God
stop
I need this thank you
oh no vasuz
nice I'm the best
I'm the best what
oh okay you know this is surprisingly
long this is a good robust I mean I did
play like Slender the Eight Pages in the
middle of it but you know it was a good
experience it was nice and robust and
long
oh
[Music]
hi thanks you know you ain't too bad
ow oh maybe you bad
oh you bad oh oh you bad oh oh you bad
love that I hate that
hi
so was a nose
Okay yelch what oh was it like I'm not
supposed to touch
I get ow okay never mind I'm doing
something wrong
I see there's secret hands
they're very grabby
extremely grabby
got it hey baby hey baby hey baby okay
that's a little weird oh
hello I'll be sure
I'll come right in hey baby
oh uh oh
[Music]
oh
okay
um all right hmm interesting
interesting very uh
oh I see
all right you got it you got it okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
foreign
[Music]
oh no am I in one of those things now
peekaboo I found you hello
hey okay all right wow awesome wow
that's great oh
cool cool
good good great actually hello it's you
again how are you
good to see you can I help you
how about this fire jump into the fire
extinguish the fire give you the fire
what is the symbology of this
take the fire lady
how are you good to see you whoa
[Music]
oh
did it go in me oh [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
hello
[Music]
I don't know about this
I don't know about that I don't know
about those legs I didn't know about
that hey all right here we go okay
that means clunk cling clunk hello oh
you don't look so happy
all right
uh-huh
and boom
oh god oh I was hey I don't know about
that one what oh hey
[Music]
yeah all right I refuse to stay blind I
will accept it
I refuse to stay blind apparently
you know the last time it got quite it
got real serious but I have a funny
feeling this one ain't gonna get nearly
as serious
foreign
oh God
oh my God
oh I see vasus
I see vases
I see Vaz okay
I'm starting to get like uh a ratio of
ground to where these things are
it's all a grid
it's all a grid baby it's all a grid
all the grid baby oh my god
oh I hate it oh wow don't like that
oh
oh good uh hello
[Music]
uh five
five five five
this is a super weird but I love it four
is it a countdown I don't think it's
code is it hello four
let me guess three
three
it's something about like removing the
soul and turning into a
movie which is inherently probably not a
very good thing oh and then burning your
body the mutilation of the husks because
why would you need anything after you
get rid of your corporeal or uh get rid
of you don't need your corporeal form
when you separate your soul from it
uh
uh okay interesting
uh right
uh
oh oh
okay so don't look five blocks equals X
or a four blocks equals X
ah okay I see I see I see
okay
yeah all right
[Music]
huh
okay
uh
equals check
okay well that is check
uh
I know how I got it I got it I got it
you have to use the ones on the other
side as well to be able to make this
pattern work because you need this
basically you just have to think of it
three-dimensionally
so because that one needs to be here
it needs that and that and then this
works no it doesn't
no you still need one more
um in the middle here and then you have
that pattern there
except for this does not that's the one
because then you see a square from that
one in a triangle from the or a line
from the other one got it okay so what
is a what is the symbology of uh the the
the the white glowing husk here in the
green eye and probably some don't do it
don't turn yourself into a husk
or um I saw that robot hand
view is a hoax band CT CT does not
preserve life it steals cognitive
transfer is murder you're probably right
about that but it's too late for me by
far
by far
uh-huh interesting
uh-huh I wonder why that table is
glowing
hmm
oh I see one there's one two three four
things in room one
there's two things in room two
four two and oh time's almost up
four two and five by the looks of it
good thing that's is that counting down
what happens if that goes oh one hour
what was it clacking
foreign
just gonna jump
yay the cognitive transference has made
me strong oh I get a flashlight
and I need to close my eyes anymore
okay uh
I see
well I don't see but I do see
that's why
what's the what's the dealio here with
the arrows
doesn't make a lot of sense
something in the Darkness
something in the Beyond
something trying to jump out oh my God
okay hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay okay I think they give me the
general sense of where I'm supposed to
go
is what this deal is
oh God oh God
there's another one is in there oh I
think there's oh God where is it oh God
do I need to turn off my flashlight or
something
can I turn off my flashlight I don't
know oh my God
okay I'm I'm going gang I'ma going
oh my God
that's a lot of that's a lot of slapping
that's a lot of noises
oh thank you
oh okay I may I made it hello oh wait a
minute
hello
uh-huh that's that's fine yeah okay
well I'm back to the normal offices so I
could
stop running for me wait wait was that
not a scripted scare oh just give up you
wanna
I don't wanna I don't want to give up
oh
oh
[Music]
weird
Oh weird
oh funky oh that's strange
oh
holy [ __ ]
oh my God oh my God what new oh my God
oh my God oh what in the hell is any of
this
holy [ __ ]
oh my God
oh my God what in the hell is happening
to any of this holy [ __ ]
oh my God oh my God they're both mad
oh
my god oh what the frick
huh
what a nightmare guys oh boy can't wait
for it
view employee to come save my ass
whoo
that was a close one so
cognitive transference complete oh I'm
free
freedom
artwork oh my God okay all right
oh why
oh no
exit or whatever that is
I mean this looks important so I don't
know something about this doll thing oh
god what have I done oh what have I done
oh what have I done have I brought about
the end of the world I don't know what I
did facility unstable
okay
honestly probably for the best
probably for the best recollection
ending you opened your eyes that sounds
good that sounds like I did a good thing
that was very fun that was very there
was so much going on in that but there
were a lot of really good ideas and it
was like a lot of the sound work wasn't
my favorite and obviously it looked a
little crude here and there but it had
this aesthetic to it that kind of worked
with the style I did enjoy it it was
pretty fun I'm not gonna lie that was
pretty good I had a blast
I enjoyed that I thought that was great
and I'm happy that I played it
[Music]